I'm gonna say it once Shawn Mendes
continues to be well the best and at his
last two tour stops he opened up about
dating advice and yeah a new album I
basically am always ready in a moment
like I just sort of songs earlier today
and no but uh yeah I'm I'm always
writing music so basically when this
time for the album to come around I kind
of just open my phone up and I'm like
looking through my ideas from tour and
just like yeah and I go into a big album
look we just want to know are we getting
a Camilla inspired song Sean answered
some of our burning questions during his
Orlando meet-and-greet and it sounds
like a new album could be come in sooner
than we think
yes I'm gonna make a country album
I just think that I'm getting better at
movie coming every time I make a new
album I'm getting a little bit better at
being morning and then this happened she
said when I when I'm emotional do I
write songs fast no cuz I'm emotional
[Laughter]
it's kind of funny that he brought up
Harry Potter because in Atlanta Sean
said that if he could write a song for
the Harry Potter world he would quote
just write about how I do secretly think
Hermione should have ended up with Harry
and I'm never not gonna feel that way
but I do love Ron
I feel that Sean also talked about the
best dating advice he's gotten and it
came from his tour manager he says he
was talking about this girl and I was
like what's happening and she's being
like this because I because this is it
Camila kebaya we don't know then he goes
quick why do you think that and I was
like well I don't know I just assume and
he goes what do you mean assume and I'm
like why just assume that's how she
feels and he goes can never assume you
know how somebody feels and it made my
relationships with people become much
more on
there I kind of love that again we don't
know if he's talking about Camila or not
but we do know things are heating up
with them in fact a source tells ET that
they are quote committed to working on a
relationship but don't expect Shawn to
talk about that during a meet
[Music]
not fooling anyone though
alright guys what do you think
when are we getting this new Sean album
is Camilla inspiring new music let me
know let's chat and for all the latest
on Sean and Camila keep it locked to all
things et until next time I'm Katie
Krauss and bye for now
[Music]